now the heading is geometry of the
parabola okay I just want to get across
to you that this is kind of a weird
thing this is a weird idea right we
first met the parabola as a shape we met
it in a certain topic good morning a
certain topic years and years ago what
topic did you meet the parabola into
your mind starts with a Q quadratics
right we had a look at quadratic
functions even though you might not have
caught them through those back then
quadratic functions something like you
know just think of it but I'm going to
write it anyway something like this okay
this is a quadratic function it's
squared and then when you go ahead and
you put numbers into it and you plot the
thing this shape we're not this exact
shape for that guy as you go um but this
kind of shape emerges okay so in other
words we arrive at this shape through
understanding functions and just
plotting points okay but as we've
discovered as you run out of the
basketball courts and then we had a look
at this idea of locus you can get this
shape not through like functions and
points but through geometry do you think
okay here is a arm here's a geometric
pattern a rule that what should follow
and if a point moves so that it follows
those rules then this is the path that
traces out okay so you recall that the
particular rules that we're talking
about are there's a point and it moves
back and forth such that one what
geometric condition does it mean yes it
doesn't matter existence from like s
Yeah right
and is equidistant from directrix okay
great so we've got two important
features fixed point which we call the
focus or focal point and a fixed line
which we call the directrix and we want
the distance from our point to each of
those things and so here's our vertical
it's our it's perpendicular right we
want those distances to be the same so I
guess I would mark them in with lines
like so okay now you'll recall the way
that we basically did that was we know
the distance from P to Q square root of
love or 1 through Pythagoras we know
this distance here because it's R we can
use the perpendicular distance formula
and then we equate them and al-jabat an
equation okay which we found to be a
quadratic now what we're going to do is
push a little further into that I just
gave you specific examples but now this
is kind of like a really critical sort
of prototypical parabola that obeys
these kinds of properties okay so you
can see I've got am I'm introducing a
new pronumeral it's a constant but it's
a it's a different kind of concert from
what you've seen before so a so
underneath the axis I'm putting this
particular directrix at y equals
negative a and then we'll put my
particular focus and zero comma a so
it's eight units up to the focus and a
it's down to the directrix okay so for
instance you can see that cheekbone
point right the vertex C that is clearly
the same distance from the focus and
from the directrix right because it's
just a units that way and a units that
way okay so that's the easiest point to
know the rest limits metric young let's
just quickly derive an equation of this
locker's is
that's okay like we said before you can
use the two-point distance formula and
you can use the perpendicular distance
formula we could do that but I'm going
to show you a slightly easier way
because of the directrix being what it
is okay so here's what I want and this
is the directrix D right so I'm gonna
say just like we usually do
PS equals feed deep
that's the equidistant relationship that
I'm starting okay now I know what these
distances are at least for this this is
really easy again I've got my X quantity
I call it let's put to match this up I'm
gonna get the square root of what would
you put under the square root
expose not good square plus what good
squared you happy with that that's just
the regular distance oil now before I
launch into the perpendicular distance
formula for this guy I want you to
notice again think geometrically there's
something easier I can do because this
is just a horizontal line the
perpendicular distance must be a
vertical line do you agree with that
right because my directrix is not off at
some funny reader angle this line must
be exactly vertical that okay all right
so therefore I can break up this line
into two distances namely this distance
here which I know what it is because I
know what its equation is and this
distance here right if I just know what
those two distances are because it has
to be vertical that happened if your
business I already have this distance I
don't need to pull out any perpendicular
distance formula or it should just give
me this result so just start with if
this is y equals negative a what's the
distance between this horizontal line
and the axis it's just a isn't it it's
what I was making out here and the
cheaper you know the vertex right so
that's just a I have that part now
keeping in mind that this point moves
good noise and it's coordinates are this
what's that little vertical distance
above the axis it's just going to be Y
like this
one or two or three or zero okay
whatever that distance is it'll be the
y-coordinate okay so that's why right in
there
therefore this total distance that
perpendicular distance that I'm after
it is simply y plus a okay that's not
complicated it's just one vertical part
what's another nothing all right
excellent so now to get to my final
equation I just needed a tiny this guy
up that's all I need to do I'll square
both sides that gives me this I might as
well expand this guy while I'm at it so
I guess that's okay I square the left
side then square the right which gives
me this okay where would you go from
here what would you do good question
yeah in this case in this case I I
suppose I don't really have to because
if a word not positive I'll take this
whole situation and I'll flip it upside
down okay
which as you've seen we can do though it
is worth mentioning this this number a
actually becomes significant and we do
usually restrict it to be positive so
I'm gonna leave it off for now because I
could make it any which way the other
the restriction is necessary I'll
introduce one a bit later when we talk
more about some of the geometric
features of this thing good pick up
there all right let's just tie this guy
up okay common things on both sides what
do you see a Squared's go Y Squared's go
okay and then I could just I could just
put right this minus 2i over on the
other side I'm gonna get this x squared
all by his lonesome on the left and for
a Y over there on the right so this
equation here is a new important form
you remember when we were just dealing
with quadratics and the quadratic theory
we said okay this general form kind of
like factorized intercept form which is
useful if you've got intercepts right
and then there was vertex one that was
kind of all we had right this is a new
one right this is a new important form
okay this is the form that you tend to
get when you're
working with the parabola as a locus
okay as was just alluded to write this a
I've pulled it out it's an important
length okay
it is this length from the vertex to the
focus and also the shortest distance
between the entire parabola and the
directrix do you agree that's the
shortest impossible distance could be
anyplace we go you can be further away
from the directory's right so it's the
shortest distance in shortest distance
here because it's the distance from the
vertex to the focus right that a
distance we call it the focal length
okay that little distance there a
whatever that value may be we define as
the focal length okay and this is where
the introduction of the UM restriction
usually comes in because when you say
length it's like okay I mean something
positive okay so we don't tend to think
of a as a negative even though if we
wanted to algebraically there's nothing
stopping us